as if the zombie killing isn't gross
enough show forces this loving couple
celebrating their anniversary down my
throat I barely remember important days
in my life as it is without the threat
of walkers so I don't appreciate having
my own lazy emotional and difference or
up in my face after nine seasons I just
realized how much I don't like the idea
of sexual innuendo and my walking dead
no one will be seated during the school
field trip to Colonial Williamsburg
montage portion of the show happy
anniversary five years what I'm pretty
sure five years of marriage means
unfulfilled what am i right this song is
not being sung by Kermit the Frog took
us far too long to fulfill the promise
of what Rick Grimes and his son Carl
envisioned yes it did like about five
seasons too long in fact what the first
community reunification fair begins
Jim you change that for reals
FAI are fair it's two minutes well to be
fair the length isn't really the problem
with the fair acronym it's the first
annual part in year two it becomes a ser
and year three it becomes a tear then
it's a fair again for a couple of years
but after that my point is it's a
horrible acronym that's even worse Bombo
that's not even a word acronyms aren't
hard people just call it the boring
unification launches ludicrous show
headlong into tedium party I'm sure that
stands for something but once I'm
working to this fair kingdom nature
Jesus even with an entire zombie field
playground to play in Walking Dead still
just eventually became a LARP version of
Game of Thrones
did you remember us after giant pictures
of you since I was little
stalkers your mother Itali it's gonna be
against hilltop not Alexandria I'm not
exactly sure when the Walking Dead
turned into a constitutional convention
and 5th grade history class but I sure
I'm glad I stopped watching before then
I also know I Rick didn't trust me when
I showed up at the gates of the prison
and how people didn't trust you after
seeing you on the other side of the
governor's firing line show brings up
previous seasons that somehow both make
me recoil at remembering them and long
for them at the same time I mean that
was drawn out ridiculous but this was
drawn out ridiculous and depressingly
earnest I knew Thursday
come never doubted it for a moment in
Virginia we plant seeds in the ground we
create you just want to move our money
around sorry sometimes I just drift off
into Hamilton when I've seen people
about to sign papers John Hancock in
this world it's actually likely that he
did what are you gonna do with all this
stuff I don't even have room for
everything I don't know stuff yeah that
sounds about right
Norman Reedus is so check down on the
walking dead at this point he's getting
his things together to shoot the next
episode of ride with Norman Reedus
during this episode our son is taking a
girl on a date to the movies tonight
these two are so happy and content they
might as well bought a boat and
christened at the SS live forever the
director said let's have these to carry
around caramel apples for the next few
minutes without ever trying to really
eat them because caramel apples can't be
eaten without either breaking a tooth or
slobbering all over yourself and I need
the audience to know that the caramel
apple itself is the [ __ ] of fair food
boyfriend just came out okay you're my
boyfriend
previously on DS of our living dead man
it's interesting to think that someone
in the producers room wants balls of
fury and said I think we've got to get
Dan Fogler on this show how come I'll
tell you when I see you at home top
because characters in this world refused
to transfer information to each other
like normal humans I swear they might as
well go full Seacrest and say the answer
to your question is coming up after the
break I didn't want you to get in
trouble but I just caused more trouble
it's cool maybe but you know what's
never been a cool storyline on this show
anything dealing with kids and
especially these kids who have zero
personality I can't believe I missed
coral but watching these interactions I
kind of do sighs well not me this entire
episode who are all these people and
where did Shane and Laurie go
oh she's uh she's got a thing for Henry
I'd say by the looks of it he's kind of
thing for her too
oh goody let's just add a set of Stephen
King bully cliches to the pile Sam
Porter producers not carrying a bridge
baby in this scene this episode takes
over 23 minutes two Walking Dead damn
you need to give me one of those I gotta
get me one of those cliche skins you
know about them down low Tom strange
ways to go that's an interesting take on
people who choose to wear zombie skin
line masks and brutally murder people
I'm sure they were perfectly normal
human beings pre Walker apocalypse then
once the zombies came they were like
well guess we just have to let her face
up and murder people now I can go with
Daryl will track him yeah let's have the
three main cast members go off in one
direction and all the glorified dead
shirts go off and the other one that
always works out well horse just means
you owe us a couple of movies when this
is done notes from the negotiation of
Andrew Lincoln's departure from the show
somehow make it into the episode now I'm
super curious what happened all the
massage parlors once the zombies attack
not sure why but that's just what popped
into my head and pants back to the rope
mom you literally just killed about ten
zombies easily so why is this pack of
half a dozen of them all the sudden
impossible to get by the zombie logic on
this show continues to be infuriating
well technically you didn't ask once I
start next week when the fair ends it'll
be interesting one could even say winter
is coming but then one would have to
admit one was blatantly stealing ideas
from another and one is too boring and
unconcerned with anything resembling
competent storytelling to do that series
you want to start with the mid-tempo
ballad man when the Walking Dead has
finally ended and has thought back on by
fans I'm sure one of the first
storylines that will come to mind as
Luke struggle with finding the perfect
song for his pre movie performance I
don't know if that he likes me like that
I don't like her yeah let's get how much
of this mother skipping Epis Kip is
gonna be this middle school check the
skip skip or skipper who is skipping
who's get bull skip skip this skips me
that's it
this is the third character to break the
I'll be right back rule and this episode
is showing it scarred so much it might
as well have been shot in the Hallmark
Factory if you think this all ends well
heads up this all ends with Judith
practicing her roar in this valley and
Daryl having him a fossa her out of
there competing all the sins back and
then adding them to the live-action Lion
King video instead I think we're
supposed to believe that alphas count
that blonde at the beginning and is
using her hair and clothes but I have to
say if you're wearing someone else's
scalp on your head it would not look
this pretty if you're wondering how to
ease the pain of this tragic but obvious
and inevitable conclusion here's a trick
I learned just don't watch the show I
haven't watched for several seasons and
I got to tell you I'm feeling mighty
fine right now note to editors when you
show an attack in slow motion my
professional recommendation is that you
at least make it look like they're
swinging that wrench somewhat close to
the people that are flailing around like
the
brutally brained and some of them they
didn't even know each other but they
still thought yep that's kind of how
survival works that's a story that I
want to tell you that's the story and I
want us all to remember feel like we
could have just heard that story at the
beginning and then had an hour of
rampaging zombie mayhem but you do you
TWD we're talking a lot of corn dog make
sure you click that Bell icon else but
clicking the little bell icon is how you
make sure you get notified every time we
release a video so click it I stand
before you today at the start of a new
tomorrow three minutes to the biggest
battle of our professional lives all
comes down to today it's better because
no no there's a council now I want to
buy some other radio ad time
[Music]
you just had to give me the care home
where's the girl where's the girl Jerry
your name you that's my name I just walk
away
who even me and everyone here alone but
I don't want your life
welcome to the head Museum I'm Leonard
anymore